>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Stephanie Stillo: Hello.
So I realized I do not look like
John Hessler, but we are going
to pertained that I am right now
to welcome Vince
Rossi to the stage.
And I'm going to try not to
touch his computer right now
that is very carefully set up.
It is my pleasure
to introduce Vince.
He is a fantastic innovator,
and just a lovely person
and a colleague within
the city as well.
And we're so excited to have
him at the library today.
Vince has a BFA in sculpture
from the university of arts
in Philadelphia and graduate
level fine arts study
at Goldsmith College,
the University of London.
From 2004 to 2011, he worked
as a sculptor, model maker,
and project manager for
the Smithsonian's office
of exhibit central.
And helped produce and manage
many Smithsonian exhibits.
And I have to day, after
speaking with Vince,
he has a sort of fabulous
history of these different,
interesting jobs that he does.
He's one of those people that
are just really sort of fun
to talk to and you sort of wish
that you lived his
life, you know?
So very exciting.
From 2011 to present,
Vince has worked
as a senior 3D program officer
for the Smithsonian's
digitization program office
building 3D capacity and
developing 3D workflows,
which is not an easy
thing to do.
Vince has the remarkable
challenge of thinking
about access to museum
collections.
And not just any museum.
Specifically thinking
about access
to the Smithsonian's
massive collection of varied,
and as he's going to suggest,
sometimes hidden material.
So today, we are, or he is
going to address his innovative
and visionary approach
to this subject.
And Vince's commitment
to furthering the
Smithsonian's core mission
of increasing the diffusion of
knowledge is truly inspiring.
So we are very pleased
to welcome Vince
Rossi to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Vincent Rossi: Alright,
thank you, Stephanie.
So it's an honor to be here.
Thanks for hanging
out for the last talk.
So I want to just start with
our contact info website.
This will be up again at
the end of the presentation.
Or you could simply
Google "Smithsonian 3D"
and our link should come up.
So a little bit of context,
we're here in Washington DC,
so I'm sure many of you
know about the Smithsonian.
I'm sure we have some
Smithsonian folks
in the audience.
But for some context, it's
of course not one museum,
it's 19 museums, nine research
centers, we have a national zoo,
and we have scientists operating
in over 100 countries
around the world.
So in total, we have
155 million objects.
And we simply can't
display all these objects.
Less than 1% are ever on
display at any one time.
So some would see this
as a huge access problem.
But our office really sees
it as an amazing opportunity.
So here's just a glimpse of, you
know, some of the amazing things
as a Smithsonian employee I
get to see behind the scenes.
And our team is really figuring
out how we can use a variety
of 3D scanning tools to
unlock these collections.
So that we can bring them
out to the world and so
that they can be used
for research education
and public access.
So if we think about, you know,
the way humans have documented
and you know, used
tools to understand
and interpret the world around
us throughout time, you know,
we've used painting,
drawing, printmaking,
more recently photography, and
a variety of digital tools.
But we've also used a variety
of measurement devices.
So for thousands of years,
we've taken point-to-point
measurements and if we think
about how a researcher might
analyze a skull, for example,
they might take maybe a
dozen landmark measurements
that describe the
morphology of this object.
And then of course they actually
have to be there in the museum
to take these measurements.
So with the 3D scan, we're able
to collect not a dozen
measurement points,
but we might be collecting
millions or sometimes billions
of measurement points
that describe the surface
and morphology of an object.
And once we have that data,
once we have it in digital form,
we're able to unlock a whole
new world of research potential.
So at a click of a button,
we could do surface area
or volume calculation
and we could do things
that we simply cannot
do with the objects
if we are holding
them in our hands.
So this psychedelic
rainbow skull we see
on the screen is actually
an overlay of two 3D scans.
So we're looking at
the deviation analysis
of every surface on this object.
So our team uses a variety
of 3D capture methods.
This is an example of
a 3D laser scanning.
We're scanning Abraham
Lincoln's life mask.
We deliver that content
in two ways.
One is through our 3D viewer,
which I'll be doing a live demo.
And then we also make the
data available for download.
So if you have access to
a 3D printer or if you go
to the DC public library, you
can create a 3D print from any
of the Smithsonian scans
that we have online.
So a quick glimpse of our team.
We operate behind the scenes.
All the 3D scanning tools
we bring to the objects
and to the collections.
And we document scientific
research sites,
individual objects, and
now we're really trying
to turn the corner to
document entire collections.
I won't go into the
details here.
But essentially the
Smithsonian has everything
from insects to airplanes.
So there's no one single
3D capture tool we can use.
So we use a variety of
laser scanners, CT scanners,
structured light, and
photogrammetry tools
that involve using a camera to
take photographs of a object
and software to create
a 3D construction.
And I want to make sure we
all understand what I mean
when I say 3D or 3D model.
Because it's kind
of a loaded term.
You might think 3D TV,
you know, 3D movie.
What I'm talking
about is scanning
and capturing the
geometry of an object.
So I won't go through
all these layers,
but we'll go through
the raw data.
And Kim touched on
this yesterday,
similar capture method for
some of the deep space objects
that she was scanning.
This is a point cloud.
So generally, this is the raw
data that we're collecting.
And it's essentially the
visualization of a text file.
So .1 to 1 million of
David Livingston's gun
that we scanned here, each
has an X, Y, and Z value.
So it's essentially a
visualization of a text file
and you can literally open up
a 3D scan in Microsoft Excel.
And then we interpret
that data, we process it.
So the next step in processing
is we essentially connect
the dots.
So these polygons are
much bigger but we've sort
of enlarged them so
you can get an idea.
Normally it'd be much
denser than this.
So now we can calculate volume.
We can also reflect
virtual light.
And we can apply color
to that 3D model.
So I'm going to go through five
use cases that describe some
of our project that
we've worked.
A number of onsite projects as
well as 3D scanning objects.
And at the end of the talk,
I can describe our whole
new vision and plans
over the next two years and how
we're hoping to shift from going
from these one-off objects,
which are incredible stories,
to scan the entire collections.
So here we are in
the Atacama Desert.
This is in 2011.
And they were widening
the pan-American highway.
And they uncovered over 40
complete fossil whale specimens.
Dr. Nicholas Pyenson,
the curator of fossil marine
mammals, was blown away
when he saw this site.
He called our team
down to Chile.
And we were able,
luckily we were able
to respond pretty quickly.
So if you look at the
traditional method
of documentation for a site
like this, you draw a meter
by meter string line
across the site.
And then you sketch the
approximate location
of each fossil in the ground.
So our team was able to take
that level of documentation
to a much higher level.
We used a lighter system,
a laser arm scanner,
and photogrammetry tools
and we combined all
of those three datasets to
create cohesive models as well
as scans of the entire
environment.
So the fossils themselves,
the pan-American
highway was widened.
The fossils were extracted from
the ground, but they're encased
in tons of dirt and
earth and rock.
So they were not going to see
the light of day for years.
Our team after capturing the
3D data, within being back
from the site, I think it was
five days, we created 3D prints
for the researcher,
for the director
of the natural history museum as
well as for National Geographic,
they helped fund this project.
In the bottom left hand corner,
that looks like a photograph,
but essentially it's a render
derived from the 3D data.
So one might think like okay,
you could just send a drone up
and take a picture, but then
you would have lens distortion.
With an orthographic rendering,
we can take accurate
measurements in the X
and Y direction and we're also
looking at the 3D data in 2D.
So on the right side
of the screen,
that's essentially the
elevation map at grade scale.
And it was important
for these researchers
who didn't have proficiency in
3D tools to have an easy way
to analyze the 3D scans.
We also partnered
with 3D Systems.
They helped us create the
largest museum quality 3D print
in the world.
This is about 23 feet long.
And for those of you who are
familiar with 3D printing,
that is incredibly massive.
Normally 3D prints
are much smaller.
Ping Fu, who was the vice
president of 3D Systems,
helped make this
donation happen.
And this hangs in the
natural history museum.
So essentially with
this project,
we have scientists bringing
home data instead of fossils.
We have a new form of
collecting happening.
We created this 23 foot 3D
print for exhibit display.
A scientific research paper was
created and it was published
in the Research Society.
And as someone who has
a degree in sculpture,
I found myself kind
of blown away
that suddenly I'm a
co-author for a paper
at the research society.
And then of course
public access.
All of the data that we create
usually starts supporting a
research project, we make that
data available for the public
through our 3D viewer,
and also as a download.
So we make the data available in
the highest resolution possible.
So this next project I'm going
to talk about if a collaboration
with the Office of
Repatriation at the Smithsonian.
This is an incredible story,
we have these object
that's a killer whale hat.
And the repatriation office has
over 14,000 funerary remains
that are being repatriated
to the rightful honors
of these objects.
But after these objects
are repatriated,
there's often not much
of a record left behind.
So we partnered with
this office,
as well as the Tlingit
community,
and really this is
the first time
that the Smithsonian ever
repatriated an object
to a community and
they brought it back
for further documentations.
This is kind of a
pretty cool experiment
that we thought worked
out really well.
So here we are scanning
the object.
Here's the raw data.
And then we took that data and
we partnered with the office
of exhibit central, and we
essentially fed that 3D data
into a milling machine.
And with partnered really
closely with the community.
And we worked with the
traditional woodcarver,
and he supplied us
with the type of wood
that he would have used
to create a replica.
And it was interesting
because as a maker myself,
I wasn't sure how he was going
to react to this technology.
And his response was
really interesting.
He said you know "When
chainsaws became mass produced,
native communities saw them as
useful tools and we used them."
And his perspective was
that he saw this 3D scanning
and CNC milling technique
as just another tool
that could be in his toolbox.
So here we are presenting
the replica
at the clan conference
in Sitka, Alaska.
And what was really
interesting is
that the community immediately
started brainstorming
about okay, how could
we use this technology?
And there were some
tragic stories
where they had I think it
was a dozen of these hats
that are incredibly sacred
and they've been passed along
from generation to generation.
So in some cases, they're
hundreds of years old.
And one of the houses
burned down
and they lost 12
of these objects.
And they're really,
and immediately [inaudible]
we could use this technology
to archive these sacred
objects that we have.
And if something was to
happen, we could create replicas
for their own ceremonial use.
Another interesting,
unexpected thing that happened
with this project is that
from our perspective,
with thought we were making
a replica for museum display.
But when we presented it
at the clan conference,
the community took this
replica, and brought it on stage
with the actual object
and danced with it.
So they breathed new
life into this object.
And usually if you think
about the journey of an object
that ends up landing
in a museum,
that's usually the
end of the story.
And here's an example of
that story continuing.
Through this replica process.
So we had a really
deep partnership
with the Tlingit community,
the data is archived
for the community and
for the Smithsonian,
the object replica
remains on display,
and part of the agreement we
had with the Tlingit clan is
that whenever they're
in Washington DC,
they reserve the right
to dance with this hat.
And this has already happened
twice, which I think is amazing.
This idea of, you know, a museum
object is usually, you know,
sitting dusty in a vatrine,
and no one ever touches it.
And here we have
this replica object
that actually gets pulled
off display and is danced
with by the community.
And then of course we
make the model available
for viewing online
with our 3D viewer
but not available for downloads.
That's not something that the
community wanted us to do,
and of course we respected that.
So another onsite project.
Excuse me.
So here we have, this is
at historic Jamestown,
a collaboration between our
team, Dr. Douglas Owsley,
a forensic anthropologist, and
the historic Jamestown team.
Another example of
a finding happening
through a construction project.
So these graves were
essentially stumbled upon.
And our team was called down
to scan each individual grave
as well as the site itself.
So we used a variety
of 3D capture methods
to do documentation.
And this proved to
be really important
because once these remains
were pulled from the ground,
you can see, especially
with the ribcage,
you can see that there's
sort of a defined rib cage
on the 3D scan with the
object still encased in earth.
But once the remains
were removed
by the forensic anthropologists,
a lot of it literally
turned to dust.
So we've captured this
research moment in time,
not just as a picture,
but as measurable,
tree-dimensional
scientific data.
So we're documenting a site
where context is
completely lost.
Once the remains are
removed from the earth,
they're extremely
fragmented and incomplete.
And the 3D documentation
and visualizations supported
not only the science,
but also a lot of media outrage.
The 3D renders we created ended
up being on the front page
of the New York Times,
the Washington Post,
and the Wall Street Journal.
And then these models are
also available for viewing
and downloading on our website.
So moving over to the
air and space museum,
the Apollo 11 command module.
This is a great collaboration
between one
of our main technology
partners, Autodesk,
they make a lot of 3D software.
So I'm not sure if anyone
has seen this version
of the display, it's actually
the display of change,
but for decades it was encased
in this Plexiglas vatrine.
And if you were an adult and
you were tall enough, you could,
you know, kind of
peek into the window
and see what was going on.
But if you're a kid,
forget about it,
you couldn't see what
was going on inside.
So we got word that this
object was coming off display,
the vatrine was being taken off,
and we partnered with the air
and space museum to do
some, an incredible level
of documentation,
on this object.
And of course for
context, you know, this,
the Apollo command module sat
on top of the Saturn 5 rocket.
We were not able to get inside
the command module, of course,
so we had to design
a number of systems
and motion control
systems that reached inside
that allowed us to
do 3D scanning.
That was really one of
the main challenges.
So here we have some renderings.
These are renderings
from the 3D data.
They look like photographs.
And this was really
a great example
of a public private partnership.
We could not have done this
project under our own strength.
Autodesk, our technology
partner, they invented software
to deal with the volume of data
that we were collecting as well
as the six different 3D
scanning tools that we used
with varying resolutions
and accuracy levels.
And combining that to create
one seamless 3D model is
extremely challenging.
So for us, we have
this, you know,
amazing world-class 3D
model of the command module.
And for Autodesk, it was really
a way to drive innovation
for them as a software company.
And then through the
3D scanning process,
something unexpected happened.
We uncovered a number of
what the curator called
astronaut graffiti.
And here we have an
inspirational quote
by Michael Collins
"The best shift to come
down the line, God bless her."
Which was pretty cool.
There were also some less
inspirational writings
on the walls.
One in particular
said "Smelly waste."
And it was a reminder
not to open
up this door for
obvious reasons.
So here we have a
rendering of a 3D model.
So we have again, example
of, we have a 3D scan
and we're using this asset
in many different ways.
High-resolution, 2D renders,
high-resolution, 3D animations,
and again, the curator himself
who had studied this object
for decades never allowed
himself to go inside
of this object because
it posed too much risk.
The object is from 1969, there's
plastic that has degraded,
the fabric has degraded,
we're able to do things again
that we simply cannot do
with the physical object.
We can look at the
negative space outside
of the crew chamber and
in between the walls
of the command module.
So here we have a photo of the
handsome Mr. Collins in 1969.
I had the good fortune to
meet Mr. Collins in 2017.
And this was really amazing,
it was an incredible experience
because we virtually
put Michael Collins,
the pilot of the command
module, back into the pilot seat
which was just super,
super cool.
So it really gives me goosebumps
that we were able to do that.
And he was funny
because he basically said
"Don't ask me what any of these
switches or buttons do anymore."
But I don't believe that, I
think he knows what they all do.
This is, I don't like
to play favorites,
but this is really one
of my favorite objects,
one of my favorite projects.
This is, this object
is in the collection
of the Freer-Sackler galleries.
It's the cosmological Buddha.
It's a standing,
robed Buddha figure
that stands about 6 feet tall.
It's about 1400 years old.
And if you walk into
the gallery,
it's just a really
compelling object.
Every inch of all the surfaces
has this [inaudible] leaf
carving across the
entire robed figure.
Now if you read the
text panel that's
on exhibit, it's
maybe 500 words.
And it doesn't even scratch
the surface of the volumes
of information that are
encoded in this object.
And the curator thinks that
this object was created
as a teaching tool to
teach about Buddhism.
So the traditional method
of documentation is ink
and charcoal rubbings on paper.
So 100 years ago, this was
an acceptable thing to do,
it was a way to kind of show
these scenes graphically
and share them by mailing
the pieces of paper around.
By today's conservation
standards, this is not something
that they want happening.
So we use the laser scanner,
some photogrammetry tools,
we combine those two
different datasets,
and we passed off some draft
renderings to the curator,
Keith Wilson, and he started
to decode this object and sort
of circling different
areas that he knows connect
to different areas of
Buddhist scripture.
So that was kind of
like the back and forth
and conversation we had
to create the narrative
using the 3D model
as a storytelling tool.
So photograph on the left,
3D rendering of our data
on the right with the
stone texture stripped out.
And then we're able to do
other things, you know?
Think about the way we have a
globe and then we could unwrap
that into 2D space
to create a map.
We're doing a similar
thing with this object
where we have a 3D scan of
this cosmological Buddha
with an incredible amount of
information being conveyed
through these carvings.
So we essentially unwrapped
that 3D model into flat space.
So for the first time,
we can look into that
narrative in one go.
Alright so we're going to
jump into the live demo.
Let's see if this works.
It's working.
Okay, so our 3D viewer, this
is something else we worked
on in collaboration
with Autodesk.
So we're able to do some things.
This is happening in my browser.
So if you go to 3D.SI.edu,
you can explore our 3D models.
So we can do some things
like look at the shoulders.
This is something you couldn't
do if you're in the gallery
because it's on a pedestal.
Unless you were really tall.
You couldn't really see
that part of the object.
And we, I won't go into all
these different tool sets,
but I'll just highlight
a few of them.
We could do a number of things.
We could turn off
that stone texture
and look at just the geometry.
And then I can adjust the
ambient inclusion apps.
And I could start to pull
out details that are hard
to see with the naked eye.
Now this looks like
a Photoshop filter,
but it's actually an algorithm
that's darkening areas
of high curvature and lightning
areas of low curvature.
And this tool in particular was
very helpful for the researcher
to see details that were
hard to see otherwise.
So I'm going to pull that back.
Another thing we're able to do
with the 3D viewer is we can
click on the hot spot areas.
And now we can start to click
around on these different
hot spot areas, and we start
to discover that down low,
there are all these
scenes depicting hell
up to the animal
kingdom to humans,
all the way up to enlightenment
around the shoulders.
And then we also
worked with the curator,
and really the whole
goal of this project was
to marry the power of 3D assets
that we could deliver those
over the web, and really connect
it with the content expert
so we could do storytelling.
So you can see we have
about seven different,
what we're calling guided tours.
And with the guided tour,
we can essentially click
through these different
viewpoints
that we're zooming to, and then
we have additional information
popping up on the right.
At this point, we're
working with the curator
in creating these
tours behind the sense.
Our dream is to open up this
functionality so that anyone,
any scholar or teacher,
can create these 3D
guided tours on their own.
So that's one of our dreams
and something we're
trying to work towards.
So you can see we have
a lot of functionality
that you would normally
would see in 3D software
and this is just
happening in a browser.
And then we have, we can
adjust lighting conditions.
We can also take
measurements on the model.
And we can also do things,
for this model the cross-section
tool might not be super helpful,
but we can adjust the crawl
sections and maybe examine
that cavity and take
a measurement there.
And then with all of these
parameters I just adjusted,
we click the share button and
a unique URL is generated,
so I can share the scene.
Or I can grab the embed code and
we can bed this in our website
and our blog in the same way
we would embed a YouTube video.
So the five projects
I just described,
that was really our strategy.
Because we're a five
person team.
And our big question was how
does a five person team have an
impact on an institution as
large as the Smithsonian.
So we would go big
on these projects,
like the command module,
the cosmological Buddha,
and really what we're
trying to do
over the next two years is
how do we document entire
collections of Smithsonian
objects?
So we already have
precedent with conveyor belts
for 2D digitization efforts.
We're working with Virginia
Tech and you could see
in the top left hand corner,
that's kind of a design document
that involves the robotic
arm that's grabbing
onto standardized containers
that hold wet specimens.
So we can micro CT scan
what specimen collections.
And next week, I'm actually
off to Darmstadt in Germany.
There's a group,
the Fraunhofer IGD,
they've created an
automated 3D scanning device
that we're investigating
and looking possibly
to bring into the Smithsonian.
So we think that, you know, we
have this incredible opportunity
to marry this technology with
all these incredible objects
that we have behind the scenes.
As well as the curators, the
researchers, the educators
who have studied these objects.
And we think the potential
of combining these things
will be very powerful.
So a great quote
by my entomologist friend Matt
Buffington, "You don't have
to shake a tree in
the rainforest
to discover a new species.
You can do it right
here in the collections
of the natural history museum."
And this has happened
a number of times.
Where a new species was
discovered and it was sitting
in a drawer or on a shelf
in suburban Maryland.
So our existing pipeline,
everything we do right
now is hard and manual.
So we're using tools that were
not really fit for our purpose,
we're adapting from
Hollywood engineering
and aerospace industries
and we're building
pipelines around that.
It requires a high degree
of expertise to 3D scan,
the processing, even more so.
And sometimes up to 10 different
pieces of software that we have
to use to create
these derivatives
so that we can deliver
on mobile platforms,
3D printing platforms,
and virtual reality.
And then we have this amazing
viewer that we've created
in collaboration with Autodesk.
But it's just one platform.
So we're hoping to
expand upon that.
So our new pipeline that
we're very excited about
and everything you
see here, this is kind
of a greatly simplified
version of our platform,
this will all be open sourced.
And it's built in
a very modular way
because we know this
technology's going
to evolve quickly and we need to
be able to swap out components
as opposed to creating
some monolithic pipeline
that would be difficult to
maintain and update over time.
So we're using a number
of motion control systems.
Here we have a cast of Abraham
Lincoln by Leonard Volk.
It's going to guide us through
this new proposed pipeline.
We have an array of
censors and a turntable
so that we can put an object
on the table and 3D scan
that object, remaining a lot
of the manual work of capture.
We're also creating
a 3D repository,
so 3D metadata standards
simply don't exist.
So we have the Smithsonian
1.0 version
of a 3D capture metadata
model that we've established,
and we're working with a number
of other universities
and museums.
So this not really the
standard yet, but it's a start.
And that informs the development
of this 3D repository
that we're creating, which
will also be open sourced.
And then the automated pipeline.
This is really one of the
most important components.
If you spend an hour 3D
scanning an object, you're going
to spend 10 hours
processing that data.
So building an automation
is really key if we want
to scale up this effort.
And then a viewer
agnostic authoring tool.
So what that means really
is that if I'm working
with Dr. Keith Wilson and
he's creating this experience
around the cosmological Buddha,
if he's adding annotations,
creating storytelling, I want to
be able to save the coordinates
of everyone of those annotations
so that this would not just be
an experience that's contained
in this one-off platform.
But that could then proliferate
to other 3D platforms.
And also be archived and
become a part or a history
of the 3D model and a
record of the 3D model.
So that viewer agnostic
authoring tool is
really important.
Because trying to stay on top
of 3D viewing platforms is
kind of a sisyphean task.
And the Smithsonian
really isn't poised,
we're not a software company.
So that tool is super important.
And that ultimately feeds to
this Smithsonian 3D portal
that we started developing.
So this is a Smithsonian 3D API,
an application programming
interface.
So that we have our
scan of Abraham Lincoln
or a collection of scans.
And that we want to deliver to
all of our platforms right now.
So we see this ecosystem
of platforms that except
and leverage 3D data growing
exponentially right now.
We're also developing an
open serious 3D viewer.
So our current viewer's
not open source.
Our new viewer will
be open source.
And then we want to connect
to web based platforms.
We see Google, Bing, Sketchfab,
a number of these web
based 3D viewing solutions
that are becoming available.
Wikimedia just announced
that they're accepting 3D
data I think three weeks ago.
And Facebook as well.
So you can now drag
and drop a 3D model
into your Facebook news feed
the same way you would an image
or a video of your kids.
Research platforms
like I Dig Bio
and Duke University's
MorphoSource we're looking
at connecting to, as well as
providing Smithsonian 3D content
as a resource for app developers
for IOS and Android devices.
Desktop applications
like Microsoft Office.
Apparently Microsoft
Office is 3D ready.
So not a lot of people know
that, but you can just drag
and drop a 3D model
into PowerPoint now.
3D printing platforms,
and then VR
and AR I think is
incredibly exciting.
There's a tremendous amount
of hype around VR right now.
But I think, you know, if
you have a chance to get
into a VR system, you
know, if you're looking
at the right experience,
for me the powerful experience
was the command module.
Actually feeling that
like what it's like to be
in the command module and just
that cramped space and looking
at all these switches.
And just, it's mind boggling.
And then different cloud
based softwares as well.
We're looking at connecting to.
So future launches.
We're partnering
with the Hydrous,
that's a non-profit
out of California.
That uses different types of
technology to allow people
to have an emotional
connection to the oceans
and to coral reef
bleaching events.
So our team at the Smithsonian,
we're 3D scanning a collection
of corals that was
collected over 100 years ago,
so that's kind of the benchmark
of where these species
should be pre-climate change.
Dealing with and then
working with the Hydrous.
And their team is basically
doing underwater 3D scanning
and virtual reality capture
of these coral reef
bleaching events.
This is an exciting
project for us.
We also had a successful
Kickstarter campaign
that we collaborated with
the air and space museum,
this involves documenting
Neil Armstrong's spacesuit,
making that data
available to the world.
And then the nation's T Rex.
This is a fun one.
So this was scanned
a few years ago,
but there's an enormous amount
of processing that
has to happen.
And we scanned every single
bone before the object was
articulated, and then we scanned
the articulated specimen.
So we're working with the
natural history museum
and a launch date.
But soon you too can have
your own nation's T Rex
in your living room.
This is a very recent
announcement.
So just two days ago,
we announced our
partnership with Google.
This involves light
field capture.
And light field capture
is basically,
it's a little bit different
from the 3D scanning technology
I was just talking about.
It's documenting the way
that light hits objects
and is reflected
back into our eyes.
So we're actually doing a form
of essentially light scanning.
And that's really great
for hyper-realistic
virtual reality experiences.
And it's good to see that that
project is getting good press
with the MIT media review
as well as the Verge.
And we were working with Paul
Debevec, he's formally of USC,
he helped us 3D scan Barack
Obama a few years ago.
So again, if you want to
check out more of our work,
learn more, you can simply
Google "Smithsonian 3D."
And something I'm really
interested in is reaching
out to you, the community,
you know,
we've built all these different
tools within our 3D viewer.
But we haven't thought
of everything.
So if you're interested,
if you have the time,
I'll leave this up on screen.
If you want to take a picture
and if you have a QR code
reader, this will link you
to a survey, so we're really
interested in feedback.
Or you could simply just jot
down the Bitly, or tweet us.
And at that, I want to thank
you all for your attention
and it's been an
honor to be here.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.